guarda c'è chi entri nel forno e viene
trasformato in una ciambella non volete
le trasformata in una capanna promesso
oggi di nuovi strega con un puro
scappare dal pasticcere pauroso fare
parte del pasticcere catti e per
l'occasione ho messo i miei orecchi via
coppa di giugno
vedere tutta la mia collezione di
orecchini basta guardare i miei video
perché ogni video degli orecchini deve
vedere altri rumor piazza qua sotto a 10
mila mi piace uscirà una nuova e pura
from mars consigliati seppure l'escape
room le volte che volete che facciamo
sul robot squazzoni commenti mettetevi
comodi e così la pasticceria panetteria
delle maledizioni e paris tr cattivo
guardate che fa la faccia paura
secondo me mita né morirà subito qualche
troppo distratta allora questa persona
ha detto il pasticcio al cattivo mi ha
trasformato noi una ciambella è pazzo
aiutami a scappare siamo attenti prima
che si trasformino belle salire sopra
l'altare le baguette
stavo bene provato in tanti sono si è
scritto che questi sono escape room
parkour perché quelli in cui devi
saltare parli sacco di cose però fa
stessa bello ma tu sei ancora lì a le
baguette vitale bloccato le baguette e
vabbè io trovo qua bisogna portare sulle
ciambelle che credo
come 61 vediamo se giochiamo come muore
vitale vediamo se non siamo allora non
troppo formale sta diventato più bravo
dai dyson peso più vediamo cosa ci
aspetta adesso vediamo allora questa
persona poverino ha trasformato anche
lui in ciambella ha detto che c'è un
tostapane gigante
vediamo dove ci porta guarda sempre per
info del tu vedi simile non cadere sotto
altrimenti titolo giusto perduto fronte
domanda sono andato all'interno del
totale
ma se stessi sia la strada giusta c'è la
fetta di pane costa sta andando
benissimo
siamo nel tostapane gigante stai attento
a scalare la sensi quando si accendono
le sopra sì ma stai attenta quando si
accendono le resistenze perché sennò ti
bruci da legislazioni berlino si è
appreso stranamente che fortunato quanto
sono in alto che bello vedere le cose
così giganti
ok riproviamo ce l'ha proprio deve fare
io sono quasi sopra si fa sembrava
facile sembra difficile ma piano piano
piano ok
il segreto è andare piano poche ce la
posso fare si sono quasi ci sono quasi
bravo ed equa servono sopratutto pane
forse bisogna saltare va beh saltiamo
dopo aver salvato devi buttare via sulle
fette di pane uomo sa cosa che io non
sono ancora ragazzi di tea vitale di
cambiarsi la maglietta sempre di testi
vestite per ora mi piace ok ci stiamo
quali assistiamo quasi abbiamo due piani
più sotto di me breda è ancora un po
difetto che ama le vai vai vai vai no
peccato adesso devo rifare ok ok aiuto
quadro mancano e sono due ancora dice
che va un pochino tosti allora non c'è
persona sta procedendo una dice abbiamo
raggiunto il laboratorio pazzo non so
che cosa troveremo qua
ok guardate cosa è così andiamo giù a
salvare intanto sono barili di cortese
tossiche meglio non avvicinarsi belli
sono stati sono affetta bisogna saltare
sui conti oppure che ha sede a chi mi
sono spettatori
no bisogna evitare i coltelli simpatici
potevo l'ultimo ce la posso fare se la
posso fare
bravo adesso sale qua sopra devi fare un
salto di stare attento ai salti qua
perché se da quella fetta di monica che
dovevano mostruosa al si vuole mangiare
sicuramente poi l'assalto per non cadere
nella parte verde io ti aspetto che ce
la faccia da saldo a salvarvi ammesso
che adesso bisogna stare attenti a non
saltare sulla farina e non solo ma ma ma
che cosa è successo
non capisco forse non dobbiamo andare
sulle fette di pane è il contrario
il contrario
sulla farina si sono trasformate in
donata ha detto che c'è un mostro
gigante mutate trasformato in panne e di
non toccare le strisce di farina piano
piano te lo possiamo fare
ok bravissimo c18 aiuto e quando
richiama aria di vita che non penso si
bisogna ricordati di salvare ok vediamo
questa giocatrice di se dobbiamo trovare
la via d'uscita da questo pezzo di pane
quindi si no siamo dentro un pezzo di
pane o mentale che queste scienze
sfigati bisogna stare attenti e sotto
c'è la farina che carino se caduta
sygenta massima fosse finito in italia
sta diventando bravi la strada è
possibile come possibile dalla fiat
brava tumori vita è breve ma se questa
persona city ma siccome ha fatto ma il
punto vero che le dette spighe di grano
vi sconfiggerò mai più antica ok ok ok
ci siamo siamo ok a malindi fondi così
brava by vediamo che dice dice di
prendere by proprio mondo solimano no
era quella destra
quale prende con la sinistra
ok arrivo e poi resterà questo no centro
ok per mara centro destra sei centrali e
poi destra abbiamo fatto che adesso
dobbiamo andare però che cos'è questo
non solo ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
ce ne saranno ripreso dai puoi farcela
io già spiaccicato tutto
tutto ok aspettiamo vitale nel frattempo
esploriamo un po quando sull'ultimo dai
vieni qua e ti verrà ok mentre vitale
continua a morire lì io provo questa
mappa giusto per vedere quanto è
difficile che bella così che adoro
questa mappa per perché no perché
bellissimo vedere i dolci giganti
riuscirà il nostro eroe per tale ad
arrivare perché siamo a farlo andare
avanti da che dobbiamo per forza andare
avanti al dio vittorio ho scritto questa
stanza è stata trasformata
questa è la squadra a cui viene
trasformato in una ciambella guarda
ciambetti ci sono le parti del corpo che
vengono poi guarda cerchio entri nel
forno viene trasformato in una ciambella
o non volete le trasformata in una
partitella
cosa devo fare non lo so è libero ma
semplice del previsto
sembra che stiamo dentro al forno guardo
a queste sono tutte le ciambelle devo
fare e bisogna scappare da cui privo che
ci si bruci tu prima che si cuocia ok
andiamo con altro uomo ciambella disse
devo saltare nei maschi ed evitare di
essere cotta che posso farcela
vai vai vai il ricorso e paghino
bravissima diamo cosa altro software
è questo il mattone non va bene
il trucco e saltare nei lati ci siamo
mai ultimate vediamo dove vediamo adesso
ok siamo usciti dal forno e dove siamo
nella panetteria
ma ci sono qua ce la fa rima con la
farina forse ci siamo romani da un
separatore sky broomball vediamo nome
preparata attenta a chi no deve evitare
la farina che è possibile per il chilo
tipo labirinto che non devo saltare o no
di fare in giro
piano piano ma anche spianata viene
fatta salviamo sia quando a ci sono
tutti un e caro meliconi conferiti
quindi devo camminare piano piano nei
confetti e non cadere giù
piano piano ci sono super sottili e
figli a stare superattenti piano piano
piano io sarei già accaduto allora
questi sono il mio punto debole
siccome ci metterà un po a superare
questa parte più vitale sto provando a
superare quella parte che non ri
superare
da fare e stravaganza ci sono pure
riuscito a menti ci sono riuscito a ok
vitale sta arrivando è riuscito a
superare quella parte fino al meno in
salita sul camion delle samb ma forse
questo è finito la mente forse ho vinto
vediamo che cos'è sì credo di sì
vedi un po ha detto abbiamo vinto ma
come faccio a tornare normale forse
bisogna fare qualcosa momento c'è io
sono vincolato indietro parata super
divertente tra volete vedere un altro
sisma dischi bruciate un bel live è
semmai che consigliata sulla zona i
commenti e ora cliccate nella cartellina
4 rispedite quale